holy smokes another crazy position out of a
night or and of course at night when there
is alexi there is a night or also what happened
look at look at jeffrey he is in the same place
oh yeah he is no somebody in the in the chat
said it says versus head and what is this
opening because jeffrey has only spent nine
seconds and alexi is now thinking and clearly
there's some discovery on this rook on eight
and the bar just shot up in jeffrey's favor
so there must be a tactic that just wins for
white on the spot yeah i mean they're going
into this position without full preparation
okay so what about we're on night after night
d5 i would maybe just castle i mean is
that so outlet whoa if you castle here
that i mean that feels well let me look but
i i think that hmm see if i was gonna say oh
but you have to sort of play position i think
the point is black cannot develop if he puts
his bishop out to e7 you take it if he places his
knight on c6 you take it and go knight f6 check
black is paralyzed the reality is white is not
in a hurry he can actually tighten the screws
yeah i'm just showing some of these positions
here and just every tactic should favor
white with that black king stuck in the
center and so like what else can you
do here so we're talking knight c6 doesn't
work because knight takes a knight f6 check
so what day seven rook a7 then there's a
discovery down on that rook stop it but
right now exactly maybe knight takes b5 maybe
you give up that rook just knight just trying
to develop yeah right i take on e6 i force you
to take with something i just take this rook and
yikes yeah that's bad oh actually maybe
you can even throw in a bit no bishop v6 is
covered by the night i was like trying to get
a little cute over there mm-hmm i i failed so
i just look at another thing just i know it's
crazy if you play bishop d3 robert knight takes
c6 fe queen g6 check becomes a possibility in some
lines you're such a i had to i had to indicate
that's not that it's important because i just
want to should take c6 exists but just have to
point it out i wanted to show something like this
like queen g6 give me that checkmate taking away
all the squares from your king it's boxed in that
would be too good to be true he has taken and gone
a5 has serrano trying to create chances but what
he's trying to do is desperately get a knight to
c5 i don't think he's gonna have to look at this
look at this gosh at a6 can he hold on but then
even knight c7 check yeah 97 looks good at the
very least because the point i've done is making
good is knight c7 you take i take the queen takes
the end you win a piece for black but don't forget
about that rook that's hanging in the corner and
the queen spying it so i know i drew a bunch of
arrows so i'll just put them on the board for
everybody thank you for your rook and it's maybe
not the worst possible situation for black there
is an attack on the bishop behind it is a check
on c3 so you do have to be careful here for white
and that's why jeffrey hasn't moved yet i would
consider castling here actually in these positions
sometimes when you analyze a lot with computers
what you see is that they uh somehow prioritize
the sort of direct development but jeffrey has
gone knight c7 he's gone for the exchange
my worry is this position he's got to
find a good move maybe rook c1 yep and it's
protective that's very important it is defended
because otherwise like bishop b5 or pawn d5 would
exploit the fact that the rook is under attack
behind the bishop but as is usually the case a
rook wins a stare down with a queen especially
when a bishop is defending the c1 square so black
has nada white can castle next the a5 pawn is also
oh man buckle up bishop takes e6 anybody yeah
this is yeah this is not looking good knight c3
seems to be forced but bishop takes d7 the group
can even castle in the end and just give that rook
yeah there is no good news i was going to say the
good news is that castling's met with 92 check but
you're right even there i would cast him yeah i'm
with you that is the extent of white's dominance
right you check you move the king away wherever
knight takes rook takes and your king is on d7
you haven't developed you can't move your bishop
because rook will be hanging behind it yikes yikes
yikes yeah yikes and my friend my good friend sam
shankland uh grandmaster sam shane club also from
the bay area he advocates this a lot uh where
you know you make a move that initially seems
impossible because of some sort of refutation
such as the move castles and he says you know
the next question that you always have to ask
yourself is what happens if i do it anyway you
sort of hack your brain into considering a move
that your sort of animal brain refutes because
of a superficial reason if that makes sense right
oh oh my gosh whoa sick blue wheat is hitting me
oh my gosh and jeffrey just can't oh that's a
huge huge move i mean white is still better but
that's a lion's share of his advantage we
need to look at that again and the move d5
blocked the queen from retreating but more
importantly allowed this insane tactic of queen h2
check he's he's trying to keep the smile off
his face i can tell serrano's trying to smile
look at him biting the ends of his lips i mean i
mean and he should smile that is a sick idea wow
and white is still better however you look at the
material it is a knight and a pawn for a rook and
the a2 pawn can actually be captured but then you
lose the g7 pawn so i would say daniel that here
is a very tough decision for alexi because giving
up the g7 pawn is really hard because getting
a clear pawn majority to your opponent so you
take on a2 looks good you free up your b-pawn
but you lose an important defending pawn against
the passengers and does take on a2 i think they
have a right move but it just is hard to play
psychologically and jeffrey is you know not to
downplay his sort of demeanor and his maturity
he is just impervious to these things he just
you know literally puts his head down and plows
forward so but this is some serious counter play
now e4b3 this could turn around in black's favor
robert yeah you're saying plow four these pawns
are doing just that bishop c5 that only attacks f2
it says d4 and then once d4 happens the bishop no
longer attacks this knight so i just i just pushed
these pawns i mean can you take the knight on c3
is that so crazy because i'm trying to bring these
puns closer together and then bring my king over
but clearly that's not i know you don't have
time because if you take b takes it like rooks
because rook c1 you say oh i stop your pawns but
after d4 king g2 you throw in bishop a3 to force
the rook up to c2 and then you defend this pawn
between bishop b2 and then you have d3 and you
win the game so you encourage the rook up to an
approachable square yeah he pulls this out and
i'm not going to speculate any further because
we're commentators and commentators are known
to produce certain effects but this is i i this
is unbelievable actually this is an incredible
resource that he just uncorked there i mean
where's my book i like to write these things
down so i'm writing down this queen edge to this
queen to check oh my yeah i have my notebook
here it's it's handy so it's uh we're both taking
the pens i don't have a pen though we need a bag
i mean i'm running down right now so i have one
in my i actually have a pen in my pocket i don't
even know why i have one in my pocket but i just
do there we go i wrote it down so i'm ready to
continue commenting i'm showing this in some of
my lessons today oh okay well i didn't know you'd
be you know first of the punch there i don't have
any lessons today so i'm just writing it down for
my own recollection so king g2 was played it's two
past pawns here and that is very bad news for jack
can you imagine after the first two games where
jeffrey was much better with the black pieces in
fact completely winning if he had played queenie
one check before g4 and then in this game where he
was up in exchange and then his opponent's king
was in the center overlooks queen h2 check and
doesn't just spoil his advantage but if he loses
this game oh my gosh that would be a huge blow now
to put things into context here and i don't think
he is losing uh but it's going to be very close
and he also could win this i mean because he's
got the pawn majority if he contains the pawns
i know it sounds crazy but sometimes these
positions can be very hard to defend uh
because once the initiative fizzles out robert
the king blockades the pawns the rook is a force
to be reckoned with on the other side of the
board let me very concretely if i play d4 yeah
okay you play king f3 and if i play c2 what are
you gonna do about that because my idea is like
bishop a3 next i guess you have e2 king d2 so
your king does run and that's a draw oh yeah
but my whole point was no you're absolutely right
you want to have d3 and thank you for your rook
putting out a vulnerable square and otherwise
he's got to find it okay so he has played
he has brought his king he's playing for a win
now what did now okay rook d8 oh are those v8 oh
yeah these pawns are too quick right now
d4 and bishop a3 all my lands well king d4
there will be rook d8 check where's your
king ranger king e4 yeah i think he just
runs like i guess what you do here okay king
d5 you can just run your king e4 and f3 and
and where does the bishop ah the bishop on d4 well
what's what's white's move f3 ah okay absolutely
so with your points after c2 king d2 you don't
have the good bishop move because the rook is
actually in the right place behind the pawn i got
you right but then king d4 rook d akin c4 uh but
then rook back to c8 so you try to tie yourself to
the bishop that's what he does oh now c2 channel
oh that is a nice move look at that springs
that off the slingshot yes okay eight maybe
his force but then the king comes into c4b3 this
is unbelievable i think it's just just winning
that is yup he has nothing i mean this is and he
doesn't even go seek you he doesn't even rush yeah
because you know because there's nothing that
white can do exactly he's paralyzed he resigns
the game what when look at sarna did you see that
he took a breath he's like how in the world did i